[Música]
como están
oigan bueno ya las hicieron levantar la
mano pero yo lo voy a volver a preguntar
porque no nada más es para mujeres la
pregunta
cuántos productos consumieron el día de
hoy
levante la mano quien uso champú
no usar un champú
quien uso jabón quien usó pasta de
dientes quien se tomó un café quien se
comió un sandwich y deja la mano arriba
los que saben de dónde viene o cómo se
hizo ese producto
y hay muy bien
pues no puedo dar mi mensaje sin antes
empezar a contar mi historia y el por
qué estoy aquí como ya dijeron soy
originaria de valle hermoso tamaulipas
el crecer en una ciudad chica
me dio la oportunidad de convivir
en la tierra andar entre el maíz el
sorgo la sábila el nopal planto en mí
una semilla que después iba a convertir
en una misión
adelantando me un poquito la historia
al 2008 más o menos hace 10 años estaba
terminando la ingeniería química en los
últimos semestres
y estaba pensando qué voy a hacer no
quiero ser godín
yo no me hallo en un escritorio y todos
mis compañeros de ingeniería se
encontraban ya mandando sus súper
currículums y la verdad es que yo no
tenía un promedio como super wow la
verdad no era muy competitiva
y fue ahí cuando encontré la
especialidad en formulación cosmética
dije esto es lo que quiero hacer quiero
formular productos con las cosas que
vienen de la tierra
y al mismo tiempo una maestra de
sustentabilidad me ofrece un trabajo en
la oficina en la escuela y me dijo tu
único trabajo es encontrar en la base de
datos de la escuela papers o artículos
científicos de industrias que están
impactando
el medio ambiente y el planeta
empiezo a investigar y me empiezo a dar
cuenta que esa industria que yo estaba
aprendiendo a formular no era nada veía
la industria cosmética está contaminando
nuestro planeta y está impactando de una
manera impresionante
y ya sé lo que están pensando la mitad
de las personas que están aquí bueno yo
soy hombre yo no me maquillo y yo no uso
cosmética
pues no si te bañas y si usas jabón
también estás contribuyendo a este
impacto
solamente en un año se producen 18
millones de toneladas de detergentes en
el mundo y donde terminan todos esos
detergentes y esos millones de toneladas
en el mar los ríos y los mares ya tienen
grandes concentraciones de todos los
productos que nosotros tiramos por la
regadera
los ingredientes activos de nuestros
cosméticos ya se encuentran en cualquier
parte del mundo en el agua de cualquier
lugar
todo termina en el mar y todo lo que
consumimos tiene un impacto
y bueno no nada más es el impacto
ambiental que es muchísimo la verdad es
también el impacto que está teniendo en
nuestra salud porque la mayoría de estos
ingredientes que tienen un impacto en el
medio ambiente también se han sido
ligados a enfermedades como desórdenes
hormonales alzhéimer cáncer
vaya en recién nacidos y en cordones
umbilicales ya se encuentran con
concentraciones de productos que se
embarró la mama durante el embarazo
y la industria cosmética también
contribuye a la deforestación de áreas
naturales
vaya hay estudios que hasta en tejidos
de delfines se han encontrado grandes
concentraciones de fragancias perfumes
que usamos todos los días
y bueno por qué está pasando esto qué
les pasa a los grandes nos quieren
envenenar nos quieren matar pobres
orangutanes la realidad es que las
grandes
solamente están surtiendo una demanda
y bueno me entró todo esto en mi cabeza
y dije esto se va a convertir en mi
misión porque en méxico no se encontraba
ninguna marca que estuviera formulando
de una manera sustentable
yo lo quiere usar para mí yo quería
comprar algo que estuviera siendo
formulado de una manera sustentable y no
había entonces me acuerdo que traje el
proyecto a mi maestro emprendedor de la
escuela y me acuerdo que dijo le dije
esto quiero que este sea mi proyecto
final porque después lo voy a llevar a
un emprendimiento y recuerdo que me dijo
estás loca cambia de proyecto eso no
puede ser tu proyecto final no le puedes
cambiar la conciencia al mexicano
así me dijo y como me encanta dar la
contra
pues lo convertí en mi viaje yo pensé
que en mexico se iban a encontrar
ingredientes naturales super fácil por
méxico tiene una gran biodiversidad
tenemos cientos de especies y plantas
que se pueden utilizar para la cosmética
dije que tan difícil puede ser encontrar
extractos orgánicos de nopal por resulta
que fue muy difícil porque todos los
productos ingredientes cosméticos que se
vendían
eran cosas rebajadas eran cosas
mezcladas con derivados del petróleo
y dije ok tengo que irme un paso más
atrás quien tiene la información de cómo
sacar ingredientes nacionales
sustentables y poder crecer
ellos
nuestros pueblos indígenas nuestros
ancestros tienen toda la teoría sobre
nuestras plantas sus beneficios y cómo
hacerlo de una manera sustentable y
juntos podemos crecer a través de un
comercio justo
estas son algunas fotos de nuestros
proveedores
el que venga ya es petronilo el es de
una comunidad maya en por plan en
yucatán trabaja en la abeja de una
manera sustentable
la abeja es libre y no tiene contacto
con ningún árbol o flor que tenga
pesticidas entonces están creciendo la
comunidad de abejas
y la cosmética orgánica no excluye a la
ciencia
de hecho la profesionalización es clave
para el crecimiento la innovación es
algo clave porque ahora con la ciencia
tenemos que formular y desarrollar
productos que sustituyan a los
sintéticos que hemos venido utilizando
décadas o sea de hecho en la cosmética
no ha habido mucha tecnología ni
innovación hasta hace poco vemos
tecnología e innovación en muchas
industrias pero la cosmética venían
formulando de la misma manera y
utilizando los mismos ingredientes desde
y aquí viene la buena noticia
el último ingrediente de la fórmula
hacia un consumo consciente el más
poderoso somos nosotros nosotros
decidimos que comprar cuando comprar en
cuanto comprar y cómo comprarlo
nosotros somos la herramienta más
poderosa hacia este camino más
consciente con nuestra compra nosotros
activamos una máquina de una empresa o
algún emprendimiento que está impactando
de una manera social cultural económica
y nosotros con nuestro consumo decidimos
y este impacto es negativo o positivo no
son ellos somos nosotros
y adivinen qué mujeres
la mujer está comprobado que influye en
más del 70% de las decisiones en compra
del mundo entonces nosotras tenemos la
responsabilidad de cambiar ese rumbo una
mujer cuando está bien informada sobre
la ética y la sustentabilidad de una
empresa toma la decisión consciente está
comprobado nosotras tenemos ese poder y
yo sé que la vanidad nunca se va a
acabar y yo sé que todas queremos ese
lipsticks super indeleble pero ahorita
ya no tenemos por qué sacrificar nuestra
salud ni la del medio ambiente existen
alternativas solo tenemos que salir a
buscarlas y también exigir las nosotras
tenemos el poder
nuestras compras son un reflejo de
nuestros valores gracias
[Aplausos]